we all wish we had a dope car right
Teddy so today I'm gonna show you how to
get one for free free car I would not
cheat on you I'll buy no first find a
car that no one needs if a guy has a car
this nice
he has other ones he doesn't need them
all so you don't think he's gonna notice
or missing Cadillac no the cool thing
about locksmiths is they don't check to
make sure it's your car before they
unlock it for you wait what oh no you do
bro just keep doing your thing bro we're
in Dawg we don't even have a keys why do
we need the keys oh yeah it's a well I
got to think for you are fine the red
wire the wires I mean at this bar
he's closing the door why are you laying
down the mermaid position
hard why you got books stop asking
questions back here in the garage like I
always say before you earn you got to
learn it's not enough to just watch them
what the hell and if you draw my program
you can be making 60 grand a month like
these two right here huh so how do we
get this again shut up bro don't ask me
questions don't ask food is way too
expensive right Teddy so we're gonna
show you how to get free food from
delivery free food that's all trash bro
tape me I like nature my bad
we got to go to a place where there's a
lot of rich kids and they're too lazy to
walk three blocks became the fraternity
well I thought we was going to break
wood no I'm trying to see LJ's house
blend into your surroundings I got the
snapback the headphones the cutoff tea
the basketball shorts the socks the
slide
don't forget the classic red coat true
now you just gotta wait for the delivery
guy Portia ek Ricky Ricardo and that's
how you get free delivery coffee is way
too expensive right Teddy Dawg my titty
me sweating can you hurry okay so we're
gonna show you how to get free coffee
free coffee and your songs B trash while
you out here looking like a do-rag model
I gotta look intimidating that's why I
got the do-rag the chain the tall T the
Tim's tears you don't know what those
mean LuAnn has them just wait until they
call out something you want and then
take it no one will stop you because
everyone at the coffee shop is a bitch
oh and it's that easy
Wow and that's how you get freak excuse
me bro
I think you took my coffee I'm so sorry
how you book my dude named Shannon
usually that works but it didn't work
this time cuz I actually don't like
almond milk
so I let my titty milk cuz you're a
little baby you don't want with titties
Oh your body Sherman